I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with US Senator Tom
Coburn author most recently of the debt
bomb and we're going to talk about debt
and what we can do about it and a few
other things about the political scene
so let's get right to it in the debt
bomb
I mean you lay out the situation set it
up for us
what where where is the fiscal time bomb
at well it's anywhere from two to five
years from now depending on what happens
in Europe and what happens to world
economies but there'll be a point in
time where people lose confidence in our
ability to repay our debt so far bond
rates are low which would signal I mean
it seems to be that investors people
lending us money are okay with us
running up trillions and trillions of
dollars well interesting bond interest
rates are low and that's normal in when
you have a debt deleveraging if you read
long-term economic histories and you
read this time it's different by Ken
Rogoff and his co-author yeah Carmen
Carmen Reinhart what you'll see is this
is not uncommon so they're looking at at
low interest rates that's that's missing
the larger pool well it's missing it's
missing two interest to important points
one is were and this in my figure of
speech where the the best-lookin horse
in the glue factory the second point I
would make is that just because we have
low interest rates doesn't mean they'll
always be low and of course that's the
converse of what happens when you've
printed three point six trillion dollars
worth of money and once that money does
get into the economy right now it's
printed but it's not in the economy it's
sitting on banks asset listing and the
Federal Reserve's asset listing what
what happens is when that mummy's money
starts moving the velocity of money
starts moving you're gonna see fifteen
eighteen percent inflation so the debt
bomb is two things one short term is
deflationary long
term is highly inflationary and that has
a real meaning to anybody that's living
in our country if you're my age or less
and you have put socked away something
for your retirement the purchasing the
value of that goes well let's talk a
little bit about how we got here since
about 1950 the government on average has
pulled in about 18% of GDP as revenue at
taxes federal government but it's been
spending closer than closer to 20% what
was the role of the Republican Party
under George Bush and with the
Republican Congress and really pulling
apart expenditures from revenue both
parties have equally participated in
abandoning the limited role of the
federal government and you lay on top of
that the career ISM that politicians
want to do things so they can get
reelected what you have is a catalyst
that makes that even go faster what you
know are our problems today are twofold
one is we spent money we didn't have on
things we didn't absolutely need which
refers back to the enumerated powers
listed in article one section eight talk
a little bit about that so what are some
of the things that we spend money on you
know we didn't have the money for sure
but then what what didn't we need them
well we've spent two trillion dollars on
education at the federal level with no
improvement there's no no parameter you
can find where we're better off job
training programs we spent eighteen
billion dollars to almost 19 billion a
year Gao says all of them do exactly the
same thing except three why do we have
47 90-some teacher training programs
where in the world did we get the
authority to have teacher training
programs run by the federal government
no effectiveness no measure we spend
several billion dollars a year on those
and you can just go through the list why
yeah I mean but this these types of
lists have been generated before and
nothing seems to happen what I haven't
they haven't been they've been generated
the first time a year ago last February
that was the first time because I put in
the balanced budget the debt limitation
a force to make Gao put it out when we
went to ask GL and Congressional
Research Service tell us all the
programs in the federal government they
said we can't it's impossible so I
mandated that
in a law must pass a law that they had
to give it to us and we'll get the last
third of that that's next February do
you think when people see these long
lists of programs and how much money
we're spending on them and have
generally useless or even unknown they
are our people get a respond to say we
got to get rid of these are they gonna
be like I got to get in on that gravy
train
you know I the vast majority of
Americans have common sense it's only
Washington that doesn't have gave me any
common sense the reason things don't
change is you keep sending the same
people here and the same people are good
people but their career politics make it
a kind of provocative statement we
should be celebrating that Dick Lugar
was primary - out of office yeah yeah
Washington changed him he didn't change
Washington I want to change Washington
do you think mandatory term limits are
legal legally prescribed term limits are
a way to go for that no I think that was
a way to do it is for individuals to say
I will not vote for you unless you've
put a certified statement out saying I'm
limiting my terms and to be fair I mean
you showed up in DC as part of the 94
election the Republican revolution you
term-limited yourself out in 2000 you
came back as a senator and you've turned
a little bit yourself again yes yes and
I'll be gone in four years thank
goodness yeah okay it can't come soon
enough that's right we've got a
Republican budget that was passed by the
house that in ten years we'll take
spending from about three point eight
trillion dollars to four point nine
trillion dollars the Democratic budget
at least Barack Obama's would take that
to about five point nine trillion do you
feel like Barack Obama and Mitt Romney
are really addressing serious questions
well I think there's a political
calculation for about all of them I was
dead serious when I said we can take
nine trillion dollars out over the next
ten years now you've taken out a huge
amount of heat from again from the kind
of right side of the political spectrum
for putting revenue increases on the
table in terms of discussing you know
how do we fix the debt problem Grover I
don't have any problem taking on this
issue our historical average in terms of
revenues has been around 18% doesn't
matter what the tax rate is you're not
going to get much higher than that maybe
up to nineteen nineteen point one if you
have a seventy percent tax rate or a
twenty percent tax rate you're not going
to get because people are going to avoid
taxes they're not going to vade them
they're going to avoid them they're
going to do things that make them pay so
18% about what we can get to if you
really think given this country's makeup
today that you could get 60 Tom Coburn's
in the Senate where you could actually
cut the spending enough and reform the
entitlements where you wouldn't have to
have it and you could get the government
down to 15% of GDP I'm all for it but if
that's the case I have a whole bunch of
spoiled land in Oklahoma I'd like to
sell you for $10,000 an acre because
there's no truth to that the fact is is
are our founders made this country where
if you're going to change something you
have to do it based on compromise and
we're going to have to have increase
revenues that doesn't mean increased tax
rates and actually the increased
revenues will come from the dynamic
effect of lowering the rates and
broadening the base and getting some of
the two point six trillion dollars
that's sitting on the sidelines right
now in businesses invested and that will
create jobs entitlements is where the
big money is in a lot well a lot of
people say that but you know a trillion
dollars a year in discretionary spending
is big money especially when 30% of it
30 to 35% of its waste fraud or
duplication well oh and what would you
take that if it's 35% that's 350 billion
dollars a year that's three point five
trillion I mean if you truly ran the
government efficiently and that's not
talking about things that are done
outside of the purview of the enumerated
powers if you did that you'd cut another
150 billion that's five trillion dollars
over ten years then if you fix
entitlements
I feel like you you make mostly minor
trends to entitlements you're talking
about changing eligibility ages and
things like that what's how do we how do
we fix Medicare or change it so I mean
and is Medicare something that gives
essentially free or reduced-price health
care to seniors irrespective largely of
income you know is that something that
we should be doing well
the question is is it constitutional I
would have a have to say it's outside of
the enumerated powers mm-hmm
that's number one those Medicaid yes so
security if you wanted to create a
system to where the Social Security
actually was set up independent and
people could put their funds into it and
they could do it that's all
constitutional you can do that okay but
the the point is is if if they were all
self financing you wouldn't have any of
the problems with right but the
political class has changed so what's
your what's your what's your best fix
for me you can't fix Medicare unless you
fix health care and the best fix is to
let free market forces work on health
care and therefore what Richard Burr and
I have proposed in terms of the seniors
Choice Act where you have a a way to
where you have a premium support system
and you in fact put kynect purchase with
payment and allow individuals to be
involved there's great corollaries in
the private sector and even our private
sector doesn't have a real market forces
how do we get to that market-based
system and I and I know that you agree
that you know markets have delivered
great increases in productivity and
service and treatments in every aspect
of our lives they can do it in Medicare
and medicine you're a doctor you
recognize that but how do we get there
because the resistance is humongous it
seems towards moving towards a system
where the patient is actually in charge
of spending money
well how you get there it is to contrast
what's going to happen if you don't
change and the question you ask a senior
that's on Medicare today do you want
Medicare not to change knowing that your
children and your grandchildren will
have a markedly lower standard of living
if we don't change it that's how you get
there number two is you have to have
transparency in outcomes and quality and
medicine which we don't unless you're a
doctor you know I often ask the question
why do only the doctors know the bad
doctors why in their transparent market
in terms of quality and service and if
you want to get a complicated operation
do you really want to go to somebody
that does it twice a year or 200 times
which place do you go where is that
where do we start because the
information I mean there's such a thing
as the American Medical Association
which is less than a hundred thousand
doctors in this case but I think they
don't they represent fully you know 99%
of Congress I mean where if I created a
system to rate doctors public accredited
rate my professor for doctors would that
would would that be allowed or would
that well you sure you have consumer
reports out there right now you could
have a consumer reports on healthcare
the fact is is what here's the problem
in health care people in health care
don't want transparency because we have
a system that pays based on the more you
do the more you earn rather than the
quality of outcome and paying you for
prevention market forces aren't perfect
but I'll guarantee you they're better
than what we're doing now and when you
have a Medicaid system where the
outcomes are worse than if you have no
insurance at all we're 40 which is
stunning and dilate on that point a
little bit because this is Medicaid is
not just an inefficient program it's
actually a disaster it's a lower quality
program that says you have access when
you really have no access or you have
access to in for your quality and so
there's ways to fix all that and in your
in the book you talk about turning
Medicaid into block grants like compared
to the state's figured out and you don't
have a problem with the social welfare
net that is supplied by the government
no we also mentioned in the book a book
by a guy by the name of Marvin Alaska
called the tragedy of American
compassion what we have done through the
federal government is enhanced
dependency we've taught learned
dependency versus earned success and if
we in fact we would use the principles
outlined by Marvin or Lasky in our
safety net programs what we would see
what we would see is much lower cost and
much better outcomes one of the things
we're doing with our social safety net
is keeping people down we're actually
harming in the book I think you you
right at one point government government
can do justice but it can't do
that's so that's what you're talking
about now for to go back to Medicare and
Social Security
shouldn't we should we get rid of them
then because not all seniors need them
and wouldn't it make more sense to
transform old-age entitlements which
come about because you're you reach a
certain age instead of that shouldn't
just be based on income at whatever well
there may be at a point in time where we
can accomplish that but the fact is is
we have a very large number of Americans
in excess of 50 million that have
planned their future based on that
system so whatever change you have what
you have to do is you there's been a
contract made with seniors and you can't
abandon that contract but you can make
that contract much more efficient and
much more effective so that the future
of our kids is not more mine that that's
actually a persuasive line - absolutely
it's geezers who are getting a lot out
of things now and they they might have
the power well the the contrast is you
know being a grandfather myself I
actually can relate to they would like
to keep Medicare just like it is but if
you ask the question change Medicare
don't change Medicare but if you change
Medicare I will actually do something
for my grandkids it's kind of like when
you ask a very wealthy individual will
you pay more taxes they say absolutely
but I don't want it to be spin I want it
to pay down the debt it's exactly the
same thing seniors don't mind making a
sacrifice remember this country's done
hard things and most of the seniors were
involved in doing those hard things
they're willing to do hard things again
but they want to know that it's done for
a noble cause well now you've taken out
a huge amount of heat from again from
the kind of right side of the political
spectrum when you started criticizing
defense spending what do we need to do
to right-size defense spending well
first of all we have to figure out how
we buy things we we want advanced
weaponry and major weapon programs those
are important things for us how we vine
there's no adults in the room what
Eisenhower said about the
military-industrial complex is true we
and and this is that essentially that
when we you know when we have a long
standing army
and a military the people who the people
who sell military hardware and personnel
I mean are just going to get more and
more powerful because they effectively
own cops well let's think about what
happens think about how we do it now
versus how you might do it as a personal
personal purchase yourself how we do it
now as we come up with an idea of what
we want and then we offer a contract
that's no no cost plus it's it's not a
fixed bit and so we have us we have a
formulation of an idea we have a cost
plus contract and then Joe your brother
says well why don't we do this too and
Jack over here says well why don't we do
this too and so all of a sudden what you
had was a good idea that we started out
on with a defense contractor saying well
yeah we can do that yeah we can do that
yeah we can do that and we're on a
cost-plus contract so they have a
conflict of interest of doing more and
no adult in the room says well what was
our original requirement but it's not I
mean is it Congress I mean in 2010 I
guess what you called for a freeze on
defense spending and then in 2008 you
said that it was a mistake that we went
into Iraq how much you know there's two
issues with defense spending or military
spending one is how we get what we buy
and how we go about buying it and then
what we want the military to do how are
those two issues related and have your
ideas about what America's role in the
world in terms of projecting military
force how have those changed especially
in your second tour well I think the
number one thing is if you look at
history you you have the military might
based on what your economic mind is our
economic might is at risk so it doesn't
matter what our philosophical positions
we're not going to be able to fund them
what are some of the things that we're
doing I mean what Iraq was Iraq a
mistake in terms of protecting it was
mistake it's not what Tom Coburn says
it's what we're gonna look back and you
say what did you accomplish did we in
fact stop the proliferation of al Qaeda
by going into Iraq no because I cotta
was
at places other than right but now did
we did we stop al-qaeda by going as
staying in Afghanistan as long as we did
war was that a mistake as well or how
did we I don't think I can judge that I
think we're going to judge that after
we've left and you're going across two
administrations with different policies
and different viewpoints so I I think
ultimately what you're going to see is
the the power of ideas is more powerful
than the power of weapons and what are
american-led the world and can lead the
world again is in the power of ideas
people mean aspirational towards our
values our rule of law our freedom our
Liberty our limited government and and
we're cladding that picture by sometimes
what we do so I my foreign policy is not
is limited in its expertise but I
actually believe the Constitution I
actually don't believe we ought to get
involved in things unless we have a
direct national security with say what's
going on in Syria now we should stand on
the sidelines well if we want to help
armed people to fight for themselves I
have no problem that we should not be
directly involved in Syria do you feel
that this is something that
conservatives are coming around to I
really don't know the answer to it
people have all sorts of views what we
what we do is we learn from mistakes and
we ought not to close our eyes and ears
to that and I think there's lots to be
learned over the last 10 years you know
it's like Homeland Security we're
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
a year on Homeland Security can anybody
guarantee us we're not going to be
attacked again no can we lessen that to
a significant degree yes for each
additional dollar we put in what are we
getting returned so having that
conversation you've never heard a
president have that conversation with
American people there are risks out
there we can do so much but if we spend
additional dollars here we made de
minimis reduction in risk versus if we
spent the same amount of money trying to
cure breast cancer we'd get a whole lot
better event you were one of the
original authors of the partial-birth
abortion ban
and you cited the Commerce Clause as the
justification for that yeah so how how
does the Commerce Clause apply you know
and we're talking here not even about
abortion per se but which level of
government is it state local federal
deal with it why does the Commerce
Clause apply in the partial-birth the
same way it might apply on an Equal
Rights Amendment or the civil rights
argument well what you're talking about
it is go back to our founding documents
we endowed by our Creator pursuit of
life pursuit of happiness
you cannot pursue life if we've said we
can take your life at our whim so it
really is more fundamental issue than
the Commerce Clause Commerce Clause was
just in that bill I mean and that and
obviously you also talked with Justice
Kagan about this and during her hearings
but I mean you you come from a natural
rights tradition so that in fact the you
know your your you would be against
abortion in all circumstances except to
save the life of the month were right
okay which is the one I think that is
the one exception that everybody on
every side of the issue agrees with
because that's in long-standing okay
over your political career
I mean you you've been a staunch social
conservatives as well as a fiscal
conservative in your first when you are
congressman you supported the v-chip
legislation which I know from a
libertarian perspective we saw that as
Big Brother well mark it was mandatory
hardware and TV so that parents could
block certain shows you had a big
country but there's a difference here
parents didn't have to block it gave
them the opportunity to ball okay but
it's still a mandate on TV that's right
just like we have a mandate that you
have a safety cord on a coffeepot okay
well they say that you're not
electrocuted in the coffee although
that's it seems that's a lot different
than say well but nobody might be but
it's the same thing well it is creating
an opportunity for you to be safe
it what I was working towards is I
you've been an outspoken social
conservative you're you're against
abortion you're against you know certain
types of public displays you had a
fairly controversial take on the airing
of Schindler's List when you were a
congressman more in the Senate race in
2004 in Oklahoma you make her comments
about of yours made about lesbianism in
public schools in Oklahoma you know
caused the controversy
do you feel and yet in the book one of
the things that is I I found genuinely
interesting is that you were you're not
walking away from any of your positions
but it seems like your attitude towards
the government's role in enforcing
values is shifting and at one point
you're right laws are pretty important
but they're not the most important thing
and that's in a chapter where you're
talking about what they are a section
what the Religious Right needs to learn
or has learned and do you feel on a
certain level not again not that you're
walking away from what you believe but
that government is not the best
instrument for pushing particular values
throughout Society well it obviously it
didn't because it hadn't done a very
good job
so I would answer yes the the problem
comes is what were the values that the
country was based on and you know I hold
through my study and reading whether you
read the Federalist Papers or you read
about our founders like the Tocqueville
said this country won't last if it's not
seen as a moral country as a good
country and one of the things that makes
it it gives us value is we put value
into principles well a Turk Durand the
character of the country you know as you
were rationalize away standards of
decency or standards of behavior
regardless of your of a libertarian
viewpoint or not the fact is as those
have consequences and those consequences
will impact the country and the question
is is will it impact it positively or
negative the main answer to your
question is is do you live a life that
models the behavior that you think
best represents what our founders
believed in and so it goes back to the
question on the leadership you know it
is can't can you tell kids that it's
fine to use drugs I want a smoke pot
it's fine no problem with that
no problem even though what we know
medically in terms of pot smoking is
it's a disaster for kids and it's a
disaster for the adults that use it you
know that's what we know medically it's
not disputed what about alcohol same
thing but the point is is because you
have one and you've rationalized one
does that mean you rationalize another
one well though would you be open and I
do we needn't take up too much time in
this to a cost-benefit analysis of what
what what are the costs of marijuana
prohibition versus the benefits because
you could always look you could always
lobby and argue against marijuana use
even if it's freely available say in the
same way that liquor or wine is yes as
long as you can figure out a way to
measure it what you can't
the problem is Mathare dependency issue
in terms of creating dependency in this
country I mean we're getting ready to
issue a report on the number of people
that are on disability insurance that
we're also collected unemployment I mean
you know hundreds of thousands of people
collecting them both at the same time
which they're not eligible for but what
we did was okay no problem and well then
you talk about that the fiscal crisis is
a moral in this sense it's because
people are not holding themselves
accountable any more than they're
holding them that's right what we've
done is undermined individual
responsibility and self reliance in this
country not we didn't mean to but we
have and if you look at Rome if you look
at Greece if you look at every other
Republic in history they died the same
way
so this isn't rocket science go look at
what happened to and so I'm not for
undermining anymore of our cultural
values I'm I don't have to be right but
I do have the right to stand for what I
believe is right and so and I'm willing
to speak on those issues and it you know
you can you can carry the libertarian
thought all the way down to two nil is
you have no responsibility to pay any
taxes I mean you know how do you have a
societal form where you don't
participate I'm sorry I'm checking out
so the point is Minh Trail problems
today and the real problems today are
real they're coming soon
the the effects of them are going to be
disastrous on a large quantity of
Americans we ought to be solving those
now rather than putting it off and
waiting for the election to happen and
just as a final comment in the book you
talked about the rise of the Tea Party
as the most important thing since the
1994 revolution Republican revolution
why is that and do you think the Tea
Party clearly had a major effect in 2010
is it going to have that kind of effect
in 2012 and B yes and it's not quote Tea
Party it's the fact that people have
gotten involved they actually know what
the Constitution says and they said why
don't we following it and so what you've
seen is the spontaneous growth of a
group of people that said I've had
enough I've seen all this excess all
this waste of big government what does
our Constitution say how about embracing
what got us here in the first place and
going back to what we know works and so
I'm proud of those there's there's you
know there's extremes on any group but
the vast majority of Tea Party people
are hardworking Americans that know they
have common sense and know what the
value of America is amid like to see it
secured well thank you very much senator
tom coburn the book is the debt bomb a
bold plan to stop Washington from
bankrupting America thank you very much
you